there are a lot of people who do
sponsored content for free because they
want to appear like someone who's
getting paid to do sponsored content
they're hoping that they'll get those
opportunities and so for them they're
willing to do it for free I really am
very adamant that you never take product
for trade because to me it's a really
toxic habit this idea that Brands feel
like they can give product and that's
your compensation no the product is the
required materials to make your ad I'm
happy to take your product make your ad
and send you back the product I don't
need it unless it is something you are
literally getting ready to spend your
own money on and you're like no that
saved me I was going to get a new fridge
holy cow it just saved me $1,400 but if
someone's like I want to send you this
new blow dryer and you make a dedicated
video on it like you're high absolutely
not that's not how it works